their record-breaking film black panther
or Canada forever is the first superhero
movie ever to be nominated for Best
Picture features a predominantly black
cast and gives black boys and girls a
chance to imagine themselves as
superheroes that's a big deal
Black Panther is also an example of
afrofuturism this cultural movement has
long been part of african-american arts
and Alex Wagner is here to explain its
history and revival as we celebrate on
this Black History Month Alex good to
see you and it's good to see you Gail
afrofuturism is a social cultural and
political philosophy that dates back to
the 1950s it aims to reclaim black
history by imagining an alternate future
one that incorporates science fiction
technology and African mythology I spoke
to prominent afro-futurist Sauveur the
course of a year as the movement gains
new momentum beyond film I see these
tweets at times where people are like I
just want to see black mermaids and
black people in space I want to see
black stories that aren't about black
pain because the pain is constant at
just 25 years old nigerian american
writer tommy
adi yummy is among the artists at the
forefront of the resurgence of
afrofuturism it's just kind of like a
utopia to imagine what if like what if
this story wasn't a story of having
everything taken away and having so much
like oppression and brutality and
senseless murder and slavery like what
if it could be something completely
different that's the foundation of the
bestseller children of blood and bone a
West African fantasy novel featuring a
young black female protagonist when did
it occur to you that women of color men
of color children of color could be
fantasy characters I didn't realize
until my senior year of high school that
no characters looked like me so all of
my protagonists were white or they were
biracial then I realized it's not just
me who needs this it's like it's other
people who look like me but it's also
people who don't look like me because
the reason I didn't think I could be in
a story was because I didn't see it
through her writing she also directly
tackles racism and inequality I wanted
to write a story that commented
on the black experience in some ways
afrofuturism is inherently kind of a
revolutionary act yeah do you think of
yourself as a revolutionary at this
point I can think of myself as a part of
the revolution and so does Grammy
nominee Janelle Monae on her new album
dirty computer mone explores
afrofuturism through music afrofuturism
is about black people us seeing
ourselves in the future knowing that we
are not the stereotypes that have been
perpetuated on us
[Music]
Monay believes this is the time for
Afrocentric art it's a way for black
women like myself to tell our stories
through our own lens because I think
it's important that we're telling our
stories because if we allow other people
who are not us to tell our stories they
may not be told properly
enter black panther with a black
superhero and a nearly all black cast
set in an African inspired utopia
sometime in the future you know panther
popularized the idea of afrofuturism but
its roots run deep
all the early abolitionists that we
celebrate the Frederick Douglass's
sojourner truth's we're all
afro-futurist Harriet Tubman son Ron
George Clinton cultural critic Greg Tate
is considered one of the leading
scholars of this movement anybody who
had a vision of the black people's story
and presence and imaging could be told
and and elevated on one hand we have a
movie like black panther which is a lot
of people's entry point for afrofuturism
but you also have the black lives matter
movement right do you see a connection
between those two things oh definitely I
mean I don't think that Black Panther
would have happened without the
precedent of black lives matter because
I think that anytime there's outrage and
and and protests in the streets the
cultural elites in America tend to open
up resources and opportunity in space
for you know for black creators and the
response suggests audiences will start
to see even more afro-futurist
art but Panthers Black Panther snagged
the top prize at the SAG Awards is
nominated for seven Oscars you get to
decide and a sequel is underway
tomi adi Emmys book is being made into a
major motion picture with two more books
in the works do you think arts and
entertainment are changing
I definitely think they're changing
we're finally getting people who want to
share it with people and people who
don't think that oh people aren't gonna
relate to this because it's black or
they're not gonna relate to this because
it's African it's too different they're
like no this is a great story with great
characters so let's make it visible and
when people find it they'll fall in
with it a DME signed a rare seven-figure
deal for the movie before her book was
released she has been compared to a
young JK Rowling so maybe that is no
surprise that the money is rolling in
before the Lord I like her it's so
important though to see yourself I
remember as a little kid when they I was
given a black dog oh I don't want her
she's not pretty because I had never
seen one before
that's why it is so important it put
these images out I loved your story it's
great that you know the of course a
black experience like any other
experience is so multifaceted it's great
to see major pop culture captain thank
you